one of the things that I think companies
do to a large degree that makes very
little sense is the use of focus groups
so think about what a strange idea is
that we take ten people who know
basically nothing about your project and
you put them in your room and you let
them talk for a while and then you take
the whatever they came up with is a
consequence of these two hours of random
thinking and you base your strategy on
it to a large degree and I don't want to
say that focus groups are always useless
and also uninformative but I think that
taking this data and then relying it as
extensively as companies do I think I
think it's crazy in many ways and the
reason I think companies do it is
because when these people create a
sentence or an idea it's very easy to
say Joe focus group 17 said this and it
can help you create a fourth formulate
an idea around it when if you said
eighty-seven percent of the people said
X it just doesn't have a face it doesn't
have a desire it's just not as concrete
and therefore people are not a is
excited about the about the notion so I
think that focus group is incredibly
useful as a persuasive attempt to tell
people what to do but is a way to find
out information it's not as useful as
people think it is the other thing that
really puzzles me is that companies how
little they understand about how
incentives really work so the biggest
expenditure for almost any company is
salaries and you ask people what do you
know about the relationship between
salaries and performance the answer is
nothing right and the question is why
don't they study anything why don't they
study why don't they try different
performance different incentive level
and see how it influenced performance
and they often say well the law kind of
low laws and if we have paid some people
one way in something another way we
might be sued and but in the last two
years with all these questions about
bonuses and so on I've gone to many
companies and said why don't we at least
do some surveys one we at least see how
happy people are on the months when they
give them you give them the bonus and
how productive they are and the answer I
got one hundred percent of the time is
that people are really
durable in bone the season and because
of that they don't want to ask them any
more questions and I said if people are
miserable in bonuses and shouldn't it
mean that you should study it understand
it and try to prevent it from next for
next year and say well well not this
year this year was really miserable
maybe next year come back to us next
year but if you think about it it's
really incredible now how do companies
decide about compensation they look at
what other companies are doing and try
to equate compensation to what other
companies are doing it but it's a place
of the blind leading the blind right and
then if we pay five percent more other
people would start doing it but the real
question is how do you pay and how do
you get people to care about their work
and become more productive and be
happier at their work and the answer is
not simply that more money is better
more money can be part of the equation
but it's also the question of how do you
give that money you give it a bonus do
give this a fixed salary you give it as
part of the benefits maybe you give
benefits for the gym do you send people
on vacation to the Bahamas and it turns
out that there are ways to use money
that is economically less efficient but
actually get people to be more motivated
care more and actually become more
productive